[Musik]
ja beinahe vier monate krieg in der
ukraine
und wir haben die bilder gesehen von bei
unserem reporter paul ronzheimer der
gestern noch ganz knapp dem tod
entronnen ist und wir müssen uns die
aktuelle lage ansehen und wir müssen
sagen was paula erlebt hat das erleben
derzeit viele die russen rücken vor im
osten der ukraine und sie machen extreme
geländegewinne wir schauen uns die lage
heute morgen mal an
paul ronzheimer wurde gestern hier im
gebiet lugansk angegriffen von
russischen einheiten sie werden es
gleich daneben weil distanz wo er
gestern noch war und heute haben wir
einen großen russischen vorsprung wir
haben wir eine einkesselung die immer
weiter vorgeht die von süden kommt die
stadt so lothar eine stadt und 14.000
einwohnern die sehr stark befestigter
wurde heute morgen eingekesselt und wir
haben ja einen russischen vorstoß weiter
der nach norden geht und der droht lässt
und sie wäre donetzk es binnen stunden
abzuschneiden und dort tausende
ukrainischer soldaten einzukesseln dass
also die situation heute morgen im osten
der ukraine teilweise bestätigt vom
branchen generalstab der gesagt hat wir
fangen an zu evakuieren wir versuchen
jetzt die soldaten dort raus zu holen
damit wir zumindest nicht wie in mario
pohl eine mega einkesselung erleben dass
also die lage dort und die russen wir
haben es eben auch oder wir wissen es
von paul ronzheimer hamm unfassbar viel
munition sie gehen immer weiter vor sie
haben schüsse bis bis sie ja sie können
auch quasi auf alles schießen was sich
bewegt und wir wollen das mal zeigen wie
sie wie sie das dann machen und was es
auch für teilweise tödliche fehler gibt
der ukrainischen einhalten denn wir
sehen hier was wir immer wieder sehen
eine russische drohne die gerade erst
neu gelieferte amerikanische geschützte
filmt die werden hier hingestellt das
sind die m 777 der amerikanischen armee
die haben eigentlich 25 kilometer etwa
reichweite wurden aber von der
ukrainischen armee viel zu nah an die
front bewegt und wir gucken uns dass man
die russische drohne filmt das ganze
findet also wie diese schützt hier
fertig gemacht werden wir sehen also
auch die kandidaten außen rum und wir
müssen uns das vorstellen verein 100
dieser geschützte wurden geliefert das
heißt etwa 400 ukrainische soldaten
wurden dort binnen tagen daran
ausgebildet nicht binnen monaten oder
jahren wie es in den usa der fall ist
sondern binnen tagen benutzen also jetzt
diese geschützte und teilweise muss man
eben leider sagen benutzen sie sie
falsch
waren sie zu nah ran an die front
verstecken sie anstellungen fahren nicht
sofort wieder weg nachdem sie geschossen
haben und die russische armee nutzt das
gnadenlos aus und wir sehen jetzt hier
wie wie diese diese stellung die wir
gerade sehen die hier vorbereitet wurde
von der ukrainischen armee wie sie also
beschossen wird hier sehen wir die
ersten artillerie einschläge in der
ukrainischen stellung und wir sehen kurz
danach wie diese geschützte feuer fangen
und eben auch vernichtet werden auch da
ist es ganz sicher sterben ukrainischer
soldaten was wir hier sehen aus seiner
russischen drohnen sicht heraus dass
also ein ergebnis dieses jahr dieses
eben sage ich mal unkonventionellen oder
nicht professionellen muss man auch
sagen handlings dieser geschützte die 14
an die front gefahren werden die not
nicht wieder weg bewegt werden sondern
stationiert werden unter russischen
drohnen die das ganze film und
russischer artillerie das ganze dann
beschießt auch deshalb ist es so wichtig
wie sehen hier wie das auch jede
russische drohne abgeschossen wird die
im die ukraine entdecken wir haben hier
gerade gesehen eine stinger raketen auch
aus den usa oder vielleicht auch aus
deutschland geliefert die eingesetzt
wird gegen eine russische drohne wir
sehen jetzt da oben wie sie auf die
drohne zufliegt und dann auch ein
schlägt in der drohne und die sturz kurz
darauf ab
jetzt können wir uns das mal ansehen
hier also sozusagen der einschlag und
hier die drohne die gerade abstürzt
obwohl es nur eine kleine drohne ist
vielleicht zu einem meter lang oder so
ist die im extrem gefährlich für die
ukrainische einheiten weil sie eben das
artilleriefeuer koordiniert und deshalb
sollte jeder einzelne drohne zu
versuchen es die ukraine zumindest auch
abgeschossen werden hier von der von der
ukrainischen armee wir wollen das so
machen ansehen wie verzweifelt die
ukraine schon sind dass hier neue
aufnahmen von gestern hier hat ein
ukrainischer soldat ein mitsubishi
genommen ein suv und hat darauf raketen
montiert die von einem russischen
abgeschossenen militärhubschrauber
abmontiert wurden dass ein k 52 das sind
es acht raketen die sind ungelenk sind
also nicht besonders
besonders genau können aber etwa fünf
kilometer weit schießen und wir sehen
wie die ukraine hier mit ihrem selbst
gebauten raketenwerfern mit in diesen
erbeuteten raketen versuchen die
russischen einheiten ab zeiten so prekär
also die lage so sehr brauchen die
ukraine unbedingt neue waffen welche
waffen aber auch immer mehr ausbildung
um eben putins mega offensive die immer
brutaler voranschreitet etwas
entgegensetzen zu können
[Musik]